subtil mélange de compétition et de
parcours touristiques le Tour Auto offre
un coup d’œil inédit dans le rétroviseur
au château Dampierre cite de la première
étape le doux chant des moteurs des
années 50 berce les passionnés venus
assister au départ
même quand vous roulez à 110 c'est
vivant
une voiture de maintenant ça n'a rien à
aucun intérêt ça n'a rien à voir c'est
authentique voilà ces véhicules
mythiques traversent les années mais
leur beauté reste intacte des tableaux
de bord très épurés volant en bois ou en
cuir l'histoire transpire quand on les
pilote de l'inoubliable alpine en
passant par la coccinelle ou encore la
BMW CSL de 1972 chaque équipage espère
rallier l'arrivée sur les quatre roues
on fait tout pour les prépare au maximum
mais on n'est jamais à l'abri de la
mécanique c'est toujours avec des
vieilles pièces c'est c'est pas des
voitures modernes qu'on trouve tous les
jours on commande la pièce neuve à côté
des bolides des circuits les voitures
populaires parade dans les allées du
château préparer spécialement pour les
preuves il faut savoir qu'à la base le
Toronto c'est une épreuve de voiture
populaire dans les années 50 et donc il
y avait beaucoup de de chevaux de 4
chevaux de voitures de monsieur tout le
monde et donc voilà bah le petit clin
d'oeil c'est de le refaire quelques
décennies plus tard à bord d'une de
chevaux de 1955 dont la catégorie
régularité la vitesse n'a pas
d'importance le but étant de respecter
ces temps de passage estimé au départ de
près de 200 équipages franciliens
partent ce matin en direction du Mont et
du circuit Bugatti pour ensuite plus de
2000 km de spécial avant l'arrivée à La
Rochelle le 27 avril